aussi et bien elle est communiste ou
encore le Parti socialiste on verra donc
ces questions dans quelques minutes mais
la toute première question est posée par
un président groupe Claude malurey des
groupes du groupe des indépendants sur
la question des chars lourds faut-il en
fournis à l'Ukraine et vous le savez
quand c'est un président de groupe qui
pose une question c'est toujours la chef
du gouvernement qui lui répond donc
c'est Elisabeth borne qui dès la
première question à 15h va pouvoir
répondre sur cette question de la
livraison de Charles lourd à l'Ukraine
Claude malurey qui va aussi poser porter
une résolution sur la guerre en Ukraine
elle sera débattue dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat le 7 février prochain et donc le
président de ce groupe qui va poser la
première question c'est parti pour cette
séance
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
est-ce qu'il y en a en séance
je t'envoie
le procès verbal est donc adopté sous
les réserves d'usage madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues notre
ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement notre séance
est retransmise en direct sur Public
Sénat et sur notre site internet chacun
sera attentif au respect des uns et les
autres et au respect du temps de parole
je donne immédiatement la parole au
président Claude maluré pour le groupe
Les Indépendants République et
territoire
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour en Ukraine des femmes et des
enfants meurent dans les décombres de
leurs immeubles pulvérisés chaque jour
des soldats tombent parce que manque les
armes pour résister à Wagner et à ses
vagues d'assaut de train de misère
envoyés au massacre
Rammstein il y a quelques jours les
Européens échoués à s'accorder sur la
livraison de Charlot immense déception
qui a cédé la place aujourd'hui même à
un immense soulagement l'accord des
Allemands pressé par l'Europe de l'Est
et du Nord pour livrer les Léopards 2 la
France est désormais devant ses
responsabilités après l'Angleterre la
Pologne les pays baltes et maintenant
l'Allemagne va-t-elle fournir les
armements capables de changer l'issue de
la guerre les chars et une défense
solaire efficace le président de la
République expliqué que ces armements ne
doivent pas être escalatoires la
décision allemande disciple cet argument
peu pertinent
on ne peut dire aux Ukrainiens qu'on les
soutiendra jusqu'à la victoire finale et
en même temps qu'on ne veut pas
d'escalade parce que par définition la
victoire nécessite une escalade depuis
un an nous laissons à Poutine le
monopole de l'escalade c'est lui qui
fixe les lignes rouges et nous qui
craignons de les franchir alors qu'à
chaque franchissement ces menaces se
sont suivis d'aucun effet parce que la
Russie est déjà au maximum de ses
possibilités
quant au chantage à l'armatomique il est
balayé depuis qu'à Samarcande Chi et
maudit ont interdit à un Poutine
pétrifiée de s'en servir il ne peut plus
être l'excuse de nos indécisions au bout
d'un an de guerre nous savons que si le
coup du soutien l'Ukraine est élevé le
coût de ne pas chasser la Russie le
serait bien plus le but de Poutine n'est
pas la seule destruction de l'Ukraine
mais la fin de l'ordre européen
démocratique il ne s'agit plus d'aider
l'Ukraine à sa défendre mais à gagner
madame la Première ministre au-delà des
efforts déjà accomplis le gouvernement
français compte-t-il se joindre à nos
alliés et livrer l'armement lourd
indispensable et quand comptent-ils le
faire chaque jour de retard est un jour
de deuil en Ukraine
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Claude malurey
cela fait désormais 11 mois que la
Russie a lancé une offensive
injustifiable
inacceptable et brutale sur le
territoire ukrainien 11 mois de
bombardements de morts et de drames
insupportables pour le peuple ukrainien
11 mois que l'Ukraine résiste de manière
héroïque
11 mois que la France lui apporte un
soutien sans faille et comme la répéter
le président de la République il y a
quelques jours nous saurons au
rendez-vous pour aider l'Ukraine jusqu'à
la victoire
depuis bientôt un an l'Ukraine peut
compter sur l'aide militaire
internationale aux côtés de nos
partenaires la France en prend une part
importante nous en sommes un des
premiers contributeurs par la livraison
d'équipements de munitions et la
formation de centaines de soldats
ukrainiens
les matériels que nous livrons font la
différence sur le terrain les Ukrainiens
le soulignent eux-mêmes régulièrement je
pense aux canons César au système de
lance-roquettes unitaire au système de
défense aérienne anti-aérienne crotale
livrée en fin d'année nous entendons les
demandes du président et du gouvernement
ukrainien rien n'est exclu et nous
sommes mobilisés pour les soutenir dans
la durée nous voulons une action
coordonnée avec nos partenaires
internationaux et qui répondent au mieux
aux besoins de l'Ukraine pour assurer sa
défense
pour notre aide militaire nous voulons
respecter trois principes le premier
comme l'a indiqué le président de la
République c'est que notre aide ne doit
pas provoquer d'escalade personne n'y
aurait à gagner et surtout pas l'Ukraine
le second c'est que notre aide doit être
utile et efficace rapidement cela
implique notamment que les forces
ukrainiennes soient en mesure d'être
formées pour utiliser les équipements et
qu'elle puisse en assurer le maintien en
conditions opérationnelles enfin nous ne
devons pas et nous ne voulons pas
affaiblir significativement nos propres
capacités de défense en particulier les
plus critiques
je salue la décision de l'Allemagne sur
le sujet des chars lourds elle permettra
de renforcer les capacités militaires
ukrainiennes en matière de combat blindé
nous avons été particulièrement réactifs
aux demandes de l'Ukraine en la matière
début janvier le Président de la
République avait initié une dynamique en
annonçant la livraison de Charles léger
amx-10rc la décision allemande renforce
et amplifie le soutien engagé
s'agissant des chars Leclerc nous
poursuivons l'analyse avec le ministre
des Armées la question de l'aide à
l'Ukraine ne se limite pas à tel ou
telle équipement chaque pays dispose de
domaines d'excellence comme la défense
aérienne et l'artillerie pour la France
il est important de bien nous coordonner
enfin j'ajoute que nous avons créé un
fond spécial de soutien de 200 millions
d'euros pour permettre à l'Ukraine
d'acheter le matériel dont elle a le
plus besoin directement auprès de nos
industriels nous sommes également actifs
au niveau européen en prenant toute
notre part à la facilité européenne pour
la paix monsieur le Président maluré
vous le savez j'avais eu l'occasion de
le rappeler lors du débat qu'ils étaient
tenus le 26 octobre ici même notre
soutien à l'Ukraine dépasse le seul
cadre militaire c'est aussi un soutien
humanitaire diplomatique un soutien
grâce au sanctions sans précédent de
l'Union européenne contre la Russie et
un soutien bien sûr à la reconstruction
du pays nous agissons en lien constant
avec nos partenaires européens et nos
alliés nous agissons avec détermination
et Constance nous serons aux côtés de
l'Ukraine jusqu'au bout je peux vous
assurer je vous remercie merci madame la
Première ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
Philippe Tabarro pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre les classes
moyennes ne croient plus et n'écoutent
plus ceux qui les déposent c'est en ces
termes si jusque le géographe Christophe
Guy lui s'exprimait cette semaine dans
un grand quotidien c'est une
illustration parfaite du ressenti des
Français à la mise en place forcée des
zones affaiblissement mobilité notre
groupe ici au Sénat a rappelé il y a
quelques jours lors d'un débat que nous
avons souhaité après la mise en place
chaotique des ZFE du Grand Paris à
Toulouse en passant par Strasbourg ni
sous Toulon nous y avons défendu une
vision équilibrée entre le tout voiture
que nous récupérons et le
jusqu'au-boutisme environnemental qui
voudrait supprimer tous les véhicules
les Français sont-ils informés que 40%
d'entre eux vont devoir dans les
prochaines années amener leur véhicule à
la casse non
l'industrie automobile française et je
dis bien française est-elle prête à
cette transformation vers le électrique
non d'après monsieur Tavares
lavitaillement est-il suffisant et
l'impact de la crise énergétique
intégrée au cou et au déploiement des
bornes électriques non la logistique
urbaine est-elle organisée pour nos
petits artisans et leur véhicule
utilitaires non les contrôles sont-ils
efficaces et efficients non l'offre de
transport en commun enfin est-elle
suffisante ponctuelle et
eric-t-elle l'ensemble de notre pays non
les élèves fait tels que vous les avez
mises en place sont un cafard à homme
tout est à l'envers madame la Première
ministre avez-vous conscience que ces ZF
pourraient être l'étincelle de nouveaux
blocages allez vous mettre fin cette
marche forcée en sens inverse
pour vous répondre la parole est
obéissée de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires monsieur
Béchu monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Tabaro
y a-t-il ici des gens qui pensent que la
question des décès par la pollution
atmosphérique est un sujet secondaire
y a-t-il ici des gens qui contestent la
nécessité de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
y a-t-il ici des gens qui considèrent
qu'il faut faire confiance aux élus
locaux quand on met en place des
policiers
et bien mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et monsieur le sénateur Tabaro
vous avez dressé la feuille de route qui
est la nôtre
les zones à faible émission
de la faiblesses l'émission de quoi
s'agit-il d'une invention française non
ça existe dans 14 pays d'Europe la
première a été mise en place en 1996 en
Suède
est-ce que ce dispositif concerne 40%
des automobilistes non il concerne les
agglomérations qui sont en dépassement
de seuil à la suite de la condamnation
par la Cour de justice des Communautés
européennes et par le Conseil d'État le
seul calendrier fixé par l'État je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que vous les
rassurer nos concitoyens et faire en
sorte que nous prenions les bonnes
décisions je vous demande juste
d'entendre ce qu'est l'état du droit
l'état du droit c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
calendrier
fixé par l'État par rapport au véhicules
professionnels l'état du droit c'est que
les seuils de restriction dépendent des
dépassements de la pollution de l'air et
qu'à la minute où nous nous parlons
contrairement à ce que certains disent
c'est nid d'où le pays ni 43
agglomérations qui sont concernés par un
calendrier restrictif le seul calendrier
restrictifié par la loi c'est la sortie
des critères 5 si vous êtes en
dépassement de seuil au 1er janvier 2023
aux critères 4 au 1er janvier 2024
critères 3 au 1er janvier 2025 bien
avant nous aujourd'hui d'agglomération
en dépassement de seuil on en a moins de
10 les autres elles ont à la fois une
attitude sur la mise en place de mesures
qui permettent d'atteindre les objectifs
puisque c'est une obligation de
résultats pas une obligation de moyens
les critiques que vous avez émises et
dont je me suis réjoui dans cette
émission qui était à la fois plus nuancé
et plus constructive que le caractère
condensé de la question elles nous ont
conduit à mettre en place un groupe de
travail qui associe qui la métropole de
Toulouse et celle de Strasbourg pour
faire rentrer des solutions
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre je regrette
votre absence de réponse car c'est vous
qui avez également souhaité comme
ministre des Transports à l'époque ces
ZFE écoutez s'il vous plaît accompagner
nos concitoyens pour que les EDF ne
deviennent pas un sacrifice de plus pour
les Français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collection pour le
groupe de l'Union centriste de la parole
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse directement à monsieur le
ministre du Travail et indirectement à
tous ceux qui aiment la démocratie
les semaines passent et avec elle
s'approche un projet de loi que personne
ne peut ignorer tant il est médiatisé
tant il déchaînent les passions et tant
il est vrai il impactera la vie future
de nos concitoyens je parle
naturellement de la réforme des
retraites certains le soutiendront sans
réserve d'autres lamanderont pour le
rendre plus conforme à leur conviction
d'autres enfin le combattront fermement
les avis divergent et parfois au sein
d'un même groupe parlementaire mais là
n'est pas l'objet de mon intervention
car nous aurons naturellement l'occasion
de revenir sur ce sujet en février lors
des débats
je souhaite plutôt vous parler de la
forme et du climat qui prévaut à ses
futurs échanges la semaine dernière un
important responsable syndicat à la
déclaré je cite qu'il allait s'occuper
des élus qui soutiendraient ce texte en
organisant des coupures de courant les
ciblants directement je trouve ces
propos terriblement scandaleux dans une
démocratie on peut et on doit débattre
les orientations politiques on peut les
soutenir on peut les critiquer on peut
naturellement manifester en revanche
menacer un élu parfois même dans sa vie
privée pour ses prises de position ce
n'est pas tolérable en démocratie c'est
la force des arguments qui comptent et
non les arguments de force la réflexion
l'écoute la sérénité et au final le
jugement ne doivent pas être à la merci
de toute forme d'intimidation de
pression ou de menaces tous les bancs de
cette hémicycle devraient dénoncer de
telles méthodes barbares monsieur le
ministre comment comptez-vous ramener de
la cernité et de la lucidité dans ce
débat budgétaire et végétales dont tout
le monde gagnerait à ce qu'il soit
beaucoup plus apaisé et beaucoup plus
constructif merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion monsieur du soft
merci à Monsieur le Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur
sénateur de mini à vrai dire je partage
tout et je crois que nous sommes
nombreux ici sur les bancs du
gouvernement et j'imagine aussi sur les
bancs du Sénat à partager votre
intervention et à partager votre
indignation le débat sur les retraites
est ouvert et c'est effectivement un
débat qui peut être vif un débat qui
peut être agité un débat qui est
peut-être passionné et je n'ai aucun
doute sur le fait qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale comme ici nous aurons ces
débats avec la première ministre nous
souhaitons que c'est des bases soient
les plus constructives possible les plus
ouverts possibles et nous sommes
convaincus que cette capacité à mener le
débat de bonne qualité jusqu'au bout
passe à la fois par l'affirmation de
conviction et l'affirmation de priorité
les notes sont l'équilibre du système
sont la protection des plus fragiles
sont les mesures les plus justes pour
accompagner la mise en oeuvre de
réformes qui doivent justement nous
permettre de revenir à l'équilibre du
système et ainsi le pérenniser
dans le cadre de ce débat des mouvements
sociaux sont organisés et les
organisations syndicales sont légitimes
à appeler à des mouvements grèves ou à
des mobilisations elles sont toutes
aussi légitimes à le faire lorsque les
choses se passent bien comme elles se
sont bien passées dans les cortèges de
la semaine dernière mais dans ce
déballage nous l'avons dit aussi nous ne
souhaitons niblocage que qui serait
pénalisant pour l'ensemble des Français
et nous acceptons aucune menace les
propos que vous avez évoqués ne sont pas
acceptables et un certain nombre des
propos qui ont été tenus des actions qui
ont été envisagées si elles étaient
réalisées relèveraient du délit plus que
de l'action politique ou de l'action
militante et donc nous serons sur cette
ligne là à la fois de clarté
d'affirmations de conviction mais avec
le souci permanent de veiller à ce
qu'aucun acte inacceptable ne puisse
être commis au-delà de votre question
monsieur le sénateur et au-delà de ce
contexte autour de la réforme des
retraites ces menaces proférées à
l'encontre d'élus pour les convictions
qu'ils expriment les positions qu'ils
prennent ne sont évidemment pas
acceptables et renvoie un autre contexte
qui est celui de l'augmentation des
faits de je pense contre les élus et
votre question me permet je le dis sous
le contrôle du ministre de l'intérieur
de souligner qu'aujourd'hui même au
Journal officiel a été publié la loi qui
autorise les associations d'élus et les
assemblés parlementaires à supporter
participe des élus qui ont été victimes
de violence c'est aussi un progrès qu'il
faut souligner pour bien protéger les
élus du français
monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
poli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
devaient la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre du
Travail évidemment si vous reportez
l'âge légal à 64 ans elles sont un peu
plus pénalisées sur ce point-là elles
sont un peu plus impactés que les hommes
est-ce un syndicaliste un opposant à
votre réforme des retraites qui a tenu
ses propos non cette réalité des
conséquences de votre réforme des
retraites c'est le Ministre Riester qui
le reconnaît vous ne pouvez pas dire que
ce sont des mensonges avec votre réforme
les femmes vont devoir en moyenne
travailler 7 mois de plus pour partir en
retraite contre chaque mois
supplémentaires pour les hommes cette
réforme profondément injuste pour
l'ensemble des salariés il est encore
plus pour les femmes votre réforme va
donc aggraver les inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes
commencez plutôt par imposer l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et des hommes
pour dégager 6 milliards de cotisations
de retraite supplémentaire
je pense à ces ouvrières à ses ouvriers
de la marée de Boulogne au travail des
deux heures du matin à celles et ceux
des industries agroalimentaires debout
derrière leur chaîne toute la journée
qui ont commencé leur carrière taux
c'est travailleurs vont cumuler tous les
aspects négatifs de votre réforme je
pense aux aides à domicile aux
soignantes aux infirmières aux femmes de
ménage aux caissières que vous
applaudissiez durant la crise sanitaire
qui devront travailler neuf mois
supplémentaires pour les générations de
1972 à l'issue du conseil de ministre
vous avez reconnu monsieur le ministre
que le recul de l'âge légal serait plus
favorable aux femmes qu'aux hommes dans
un premier temps par vos propres aveux
vous établissez l'injustice de votre
texte nous vous demandons de le retirer
et d'organiser un véritable débat dans
le pays
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministres du travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion monsieur Duchamp
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice principaleau quelques mots
pour revenir sur les faits que vous
évoquez et sur la lecture qui peut être
faite parfois ici ou ailleurs d'ailleurs
de l'étude d'un pacte qui accompagne le
projet de loi de réforme des retraites
peut-être en rappelant quelques
évidences mais qu'il vous faut rappeler
dans un tel débat est-ce que l'âge
d'ouverture des droits sera différente
entre les hommes et les femmes non
est-ce que la durée de cotisation
requise entre les hommes et les femmes
portera une différence évidemment non
quel est les conséquences de la réforme
que nous portons il y a effectivement un
rapprochement de l'âge effectif je ne
parle pas de l'âge légal mais
effectivement de départ entre les âmes
et les femmes mais vous l'avez
certainement noté madame la sénatrice à
la lecture de ce rapport d'évaluation en
2030 les femmes continueront à partir
plus jeune que les hommes à la retraite
et pourquoi elles pourront continuer à
partir plus jeune que les hommes à la
retraite parce que nous maintenons
l'intégralité de ce que nous appelons
les droits familiaux les quatre
trimestres automatiquement attribué aux
femmes à l'occasion d'une maternité ces
quatre pour le régime général de pour le
régime de la fonction publique et vous
savez que dans le régime général il y en
a quatre qui peuvent être répartis
librement entre les membres du couple
vous avez aussi vu madame la sénatrice
dans ce même rapport d'évaluation que
les mesures que nous prenons en matière
d'éligibilité à la retraite minimale
garantie commente matière d'éligibilité
au départ anticipé au bénéfice des
carrières longues sont favorables aux
femmes parce que nous intégrons les
trimestres cotisés au titre de
l'assurance vieillesse des parents au
foyer dans les trimestres qui pour
déterminer cette éligibilité tant au
minimum de pension qu'aux dispositif de
départ anticipé pour carrière longue
nous avons veillé ce queuleusement avec
un chef de gouvernement dans chacune des
décisions que nous avions à prendre à
protéger les plus fragiles tous les
exemples que vous avez cités tous les
métiers que vous avez évoqué font partie
de ceux qui seront mieux protégés et
mieux accompagnés tant par les
dispositifs de pénibilité que par le
nouveau dispositif de prise en compte
des carrières longues pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler avant 18 ans je
suis sûr que des bains nous trouvons des
convergences sur ces points là
pour se poli pour quelques secondes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre vous avez refusé
l'étude d'impact vous êtes incapable
aujourd'hui de nous donner le nombre de
françaises qui de français d'ailleurs
qui bénéficierait des 1200 euros brutes
monsieur le ministre il y a 10 ans vous
étiez le grand défenseur de la retraite
à 60 ans vous avez changé évidemment
d'avis entre deux mais ce n'est pas
étonnant de votre part
la parole est de notre collègue Ludovic
et pour le compte du rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Sébastien Lecornu ministre des
Armées monsieur le ministre le 20
janvier dernier lors de la présentation
de série aux armées à Mont-de-Marsan le
président de la République a indiqué que
la France a loué à ses armées un budget
davantage conséquent sur la période 2024
la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire articulée autour de quatre
pivots principaux à savoir notre cœur de
souveraineté la haute intensité la
protection de nos intérêts et nos
partenariats renouvelés attribuera 413
milliards d'euros aux forces armées soit
118 milliards de plus que la loi de
programmation militaire actuelle même
s'il convient de tenir compte d'un
présent contexte inflationniste le
président de la République a rappelé le
contexte particulier de menaces dans
lequel nous sommes et l'émergence des
formes de conflictualité nouvelles cet
effort conséquent rassure non seulement
notre communauté militaire nos décideurs
et nos élus mais également notre
communauté et qu'il traduit de faire de
du président de la France un président
plus souverain plus entreprenant et plus
agile
c'était fort ne permettra
indubitablement d'avoir une guerre
d'avance notre Parlement il veillera
notre souveraineté passera non seulement
par le renfort de notre dissuasion par
nos postures permanentes mais aussi par
la résilience nationale il est vrai
qu'il nous faut agir partout plus vite
et plus fort
cette dernière LPM placée sous le signe
de la transformation prendra le relais
de l'ancienne qui avait déjà été marqué
par un effort signatricatif en matière
de réparation cela demandera sûrement
une forme d'agilité car comme vous le
savez de nombreuses infrastructures
dépendent totalement du matériel qu'elle
supporte je pense notamment au base
aérienne exclusivement équipée de
d'avions de type mirage ou
d'établissement de type psaïque qui
maintiennent aujourd'hui des
hélicoptères d'anciennes génération de
type gazelle ou type Puma et qui peinent
à se projeter dans l'avenir monsieur le
ministre dans un contexte où la
souveraineté est redevenu un axe de
réflexion important de tout premier plan
comment pensez-vous concilier cette
politique forte de transformation avec
le développement de nos infrastructures
militaires et de notre industrie de
défense dans nos territoires monsieur le
ministre comment souhaitez-vous associer
les territoires à cet effort inédit sans
égal mesures depuis la présidence du
général de Gaulle
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre des Armées monsieur Sébastien
Lecornu de merci monsieur le Président
du Sénat mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bon le
ministère des armées est un grand
ministère territorial et pour cause il
est représenté présent dans les
différents territoires et donc de fait
en deux minutes lister les impacts de
l'autre programmation militaire et très
difficile je vais essayer de donner
quelques lignes bon un déjà la
réparation continue et c'est
particulièrement vrai sur les
infrastructures on le sait très bien
beaucoup de régiment beaucoup de base
navales beaucoup de base aériennes sont
encore dans un état absolument
déplorable fruits de décision qui
parfois ont été prises il y a très
longtemps et sur lequel la réparation
prendra du temps il faut donc le dire
avec humilité la deuxième des choses la
réparation continue sur les services de
soutien c'est particulièrement vrai pour
le commissariat c'est vrai pour le
service de santé des armées je sais que
c'est un sujet qui est suivi par les
membres de la commission de la défense
et des forces armées du Sénat et là on
le voit bien c'est soutiens aussi ont
été abîmés la réparation prendra du
temps dans des contextes qui sont
difficiles alors vu quand on parle de
transformation
il va sans dire que cette transformation
vont être moins spectaculaire sur les
territoires que dans le passé et pour
cause déjà parce qu'on ne ferme aucun
régiment aucune base aérienne aucun
laboratoire de la DGA donc par
définition c'est une transformation
interne à bas prix c'est vrai sur le
terrain technologique vous l'avez
visitez le Scorpion rafale il y a des
sauts technologiques qui sont importants
et qui vont forcément transformer la vie
des unités c'est vrai également sur les
métiers nouveau le cyber le spatial les
fonds sous-marins dans l'occasion d'y
revenir ici même c'est vrai également
aussi la transformation RH du ministère
puisque vous aurez forcément un pivot en
matière de ressources humaines liée soit
aux réserves avec un nouveau ratio de
réserviste sera un impact important pour
les régiments de l'armée terre et dans
le grand est singulièrement on fera
amener à y revenir dans les temps qui
viendront c'est vrai aussi pour le
pyramidage entre les sous-officiers et
la troupe puisque les fonctions
nouvelles qui amènent se sautent
technologies demande aussi évidemment
beaucoup plus de savoir-faire en tout
cas de monter en puissance de
compétences je reviendrai vers vous sur
ces sujets on peut aussi citer secondes
l'impact en matière d'emploi pour la
BITD aux quatre coins de l'hexagone une
feuille de route pour l'outre-mer que le
Président de la République vaudra
détailler lui-même sur les impacts de
notre programmation militaire pour nos
territoires
ultramarins et la relation avec les
collectivités territoriales sur lequel
je veux qu'on arrive à systématiser les
choses notamment pour le plan famille
merci Monsieur merci
je vais donner la parole maintenant à la
présidente Laurence Rossignol pour le
groupe socialiste écologiste et
République
merci monsieur le Président lundi le
Haut Conseil à l'égalité a rendu son
rapport ce rapport confié de la
persistance du sexisme au niveau dans
notre société ce qui explique d'ailleurs
que la condition des femmes reste
soumise aux inégalités et aux violences
c'était consistème sexiste impose aux
femmes de tout toujours devoir s'adapter
et esquiver
c'est un effort constant et puisqu'on
parle d'effort le même jour avec un sens
du timing étonnant le ministre Riester
dans un moment de franchise merveilleux
a dit en effet cette réforme va demander
aux femmes un effort supplémentaire
alors je dis clairement pour ce qui est
des femmes les efforts c'est non on en
fait déjà assez comme ça tout le temps
alors
vous répétez en boucle que la pension
minimum va passer maintenant à 1200
euros mais les conditions d'accès à
cette pension celle d'une carrière
complète sont tellement drastiques que
justement elles vont éviter les femmes
les femmes justement ont des carrières
arrachées elles ne pourront pas profiter
de cette de cette pension à 1200 euros
dont vous nous parlez par ailleurs il y
a une chose question c'est qu'elles vont
devoir travailler plus longtemps et non
seulement plus longtemps mais plus
longtemps que les hommes qui vont devoir
travailler plus longtemps puisque selon
les études des experts ce sera le double
d'un allongement de la durée du travail
pour les femmes appartenaient à partir
de 1972 c'est un peu compliqué mais ça
prouve quand même que votre réforme
accroît les inégalités entre les femmes
et les hommes comme toutes les réformes
qui sont supposées neutres et qui en
réalité accroissant les inégalités alors
puisqu'on parle d'effort les femmes en
font beaucoup je l'ai déjà dit madame la
Première ministre vous vous pouvez en
faire un vous êtes la femme qui peut
faire un bel effort en renonçant à cette
retraite injuste pour les femmes
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste du travail il pleine emploi
de l'insertion merci monsieur le
président madame la Présidente Rossignol
je ne reviens pas sur les éléments que
j'ai donné en réponse à madame la
sénatrice du groupe communiste
précédemment simplement vous dire un
certain nombre de choses la réforme que
nous menons est une réforme qui porte
des protections pour les femmes vous
avez du mal à l'entendre je crois ou à
le concevoir mais au-delà des
dispositions que nous prenons il y en a
une que je n'ai pas rappelé qui est que
nous avons veillé parce que là je
suppression de la décote soit maintenu à
67 ans l'âge de suppression de décote
d'aujourd'hui parce que 20% des femmes
ont une carrière incomplète et que ce
sont l'essentiel des celles et ceux qui
vont jusqu'à 67 ans qui justement sont
des fans nous veillons avec la retraite
minimum à ce que justement les femmes
qui ont les carrières les plus fragiles
les carrières hachées vous avez décrites
les carrières avec les revenus les plus
bas soit bénéficiaires la retraite
minimum que nous mettons en place va
permettre à 200 000 nouveaux retraités
par an c'est à dire un départ à la
retraite sur 4
de bénéficier d'une pension meilleure
avec la réforme que sans la réforme et
les deux tiers se bénéficiaires sont des
femmes parce que justement et là je vous
rejoins les femmes sont les plus
exposées à la précarité et aux carrières
agées le temps me manque pour décrire
les mécanismes mais le fait que nous
ayons fait le choix de revaloriser le
minimum contributif majoré qui est
accessible dès 120 trimestres cotisés le
fait que nous ayons fait le choix de
revalorer le minimum le revaloriser le
minimum contributif de base accessible à
toutes celles et ceux qui ont travaillé
permet justement de protéger les plus
fragiles nous n'avons pas les mêmes
priorités madame la sénatrice vous
parlez de carrière complète nous pas
vous parler de carrière complète nous
nous adressons justement à celles qui
n'ont pas des carrières complètes et qui
bénéficieront des revalorisations et des
systèmes de protection que nous mettons
en place c'est ça notre priorité
protégez les plus fragiles protéger
celles et ceux qui sont exposés à la
précarité et aux difficultés de carrière
c'est avec cette loi que nous allons
faire et c'est avec ces dispositions que
nous allons y arriver je termine par un
point pour soutenir un point d'accord
avec votre question vous avez cité le
rapport au conseil et l'égalité et ce
conseil montre aussi que notre système
de retraite qu'on accuse parfois tous
les mots est aussi le réceptacle d'une
vie d'inégalité travaillons sur ces
inégalités faisant en sorte de les
résorber et les retraites seront
beaucoup plus justes tout le monde en
fera sa discret merci
la parole est à notre collègue Henri
Cabanel pour le gros du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Agriculture de la
souveraineté alimentaire la viticulture
et la filière qui a subi le plus d'aller
à successifs lundi le président de la
Chambre d'agriculture de l'Hérault a
pris l'initiative d'une réunion en
urgence pour alerter les parlementaires
de cette crise sans précédent 2019 taxe
Trump
2020-2021 covid 2021 énorme gel de la
grêle de la sécheresse 2022 guerre en
Ukraine avec ses conséquences
économiques au-delà du drame humain
pénurie de bouteilles augmentation du
prix du verre des engrais du carton etc
et l'inflation qui est un impact direct
sur la consommation par exemple - 15%
sur les vins rouges un chiffre très
inquiétant car la viticulture française
est un secteur qui réalise depuis de 14
milliards d'euros d'excellents
commercial le Bordelais a récemment
manifesté sa colère car le désespoir
gagne ses vignerons nous venons avec le
groupe vinie 20 avant la séance reçue un
collectif de viticulteurs bordelais
abattu des espérés mais combattif
lundi le président des Gias de l'Hérault
consterné à souligner la catastrophe du
contexte pour les jeunes installés
depuis deux trois ans qui accumule les
galères et les crises alors que leur
projet diticoles est parfaitement sain
si une remise en question structurelle
est nécessaire et les organismes
professionnels ça l'empare que
proposez-vous monsieur le ministre pour
aider cette filière allez-vous soutenir
la demande de d'étalement de
remboursement des PGE de 6 à 10 ans
allez-vous répondre à la demande de
distillation adossé à la recherche
temporaire ou définitif à l'aide de
stockage allez-vous soutenir la création
d'un plan de relance commerciale
[Musique]
c'est la poursuite du PGE nous y
travaillons avec le ministère de
l'économie et des finances pour voir
dans quelles conditions ça peut se faire
le deuxième élément c'est l'aide au
stockage ou à la distillation qui peut
être un élément complémentaire pour
régler le trop sur les choses et puis le
troisième élément qui est un élément
plus structurel qui est l'arrachage
pense en particulier à ce qui se passe
dans le Bordelais pour réguler une
surproduction qui est surproduction
structurelle pour le coup et puis
évidemment nous devons travailler sur ce
que vous avez dit c'est à dire la
capacité qu'à cette filière a aussi ou
s'ouvrir des perspectives à l'export il
y a une évolution des modes de
consommation et il faut qu'on puisse en
tenir compte de l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs qu'on est en train
d'expertiser c'est compliqué pour chacun
d'entre eux à la fois pour des raisons
budgétaires pour le PGE c'est compliqué
aussi pour d'autres raisons donc on a
besoin de regarder précisément ce qu'on
peut faire et on dira en vérité ce qu'on
peut faire est-ce qu'on peut pas faire
aux filières je vais réunirai au tout
début du mois de février pour regarder
l'ensemble des distributifs et apporter
des premières réponses concrètes
reconnaissons aussi qu'un certain nombre
de dispositifs qui relève du règlement
communautaire je pense en particulier à
la recherche qui nécessite du temps donc
j'ai besoin avec vous et avec eux de
construire des mesures d'urgence et puis
à mesure qu'il leur donne des
perspectives sur le moyen long terme
parce que c'est bien c'est deux tensions
qu'il faut essayer de de conjurer et
aussi en tout cas en particulier pour
les jeunes mais pas pas seulement de
leur donner des perspectives parce que
la crise est en effet assez grave
merci monsieur le ministre de ces
réponses vous savez nous sommes nombreux
sur tous ces bancs à vouloir que la
France reste la référence mondiale au
niveau du vin vous l'avez dit la
situation est grave mais et certainement
elle est pas désespérée aussi je vous
propose donc de vous appuyer sur tous
les parlementaires au-delà de votre
majorité qui connaissent parfaitement
leur territoire parce que l'union fait
la force et je crois que la viticulture
a besoin de ça merci merci la parole est
à notre collègue Guy benaroche pour le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de la Justice et
concerne les quartiers disciplinaires
ces lieux ne sont pas perçus par hasard
comme des lieux de moindre droit les
conditions de vie sont plus dures qu'en
détention générale les garanties comme
la superficie médiévale des cellules la
possibilité de promenade la possibilité
de contact avec l'extérieur par les
droits de visite ou par le téléphone
semble parfois oublier l'État français
ne brille pas par l'état de ses prisons
et par les conditions de détention les
quartiers disciplinaires sur le reflet
exacerbé de ces problèmes et le Comité
pour la protection contre la torture du
Conseil de l'Europe alors de sa visite
établit de nouveaux des constats qui ne
nous font pas odeur actuellement la
durée maximale y est de 30 jours le
comité a recommandé à nouveau aux
autorités françaises de prendre les
mesures législatives nécessaires pour
assurer que le placement à l'isolement
disciplinaire ne dépasse pas 14 jours
pour une infraction donnée commise par
un adulte et soit de préférence d'une
durée inférieure ces recommandations
nous paraissent nécessaires et le début
d'une réelle prise en compte des
difficultés au sein des quartiers
disciplinaires et je me dois d'évoquer
les doutes portées sur les mauvais
traitements et le de transparence de
traçabilité qui est hélas fait croître
les doutes et les suspicions entre
autres sur les circonstances de certains
événements et certains suicides suicides
qui semble aussi plus important dans ces
lieux où les privations peuvent créer
des conditions favorables au passage à
l'acte le CPT regrette aussi que le
recours à la force qui peut parfois
parfois se justifier ne soit pas
systématiquement répertorié et quand il
est que les données de permettent pas de
démontrer en quoi celui-ci s'avère
strictement nécessaire et appliqué dans
le respect du principe de
proportionnalité aussi je souhaiterais
savoir si le ministère contrôle
disponible les chiffres liés au quartier
disciplinaire nombre de séjour durée
durée moyenne nombre de suicides afin de
permettre à l'état des lieux de la
situation et pour enclencher une réforme
des quartiers disciplinaire je
souhaiterais aussi connaître votre avis
sur les possibilités d'aménager les
restrictions aux conséquences trop
importantes sur les détenus des
quartiers disciplinaires
pour vous répondre la parole est au
garde des souvenirs de la justice
Monsieur Eric Dupont-Moretti merci
monsieur le Président du Sénat et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
sénateur benaroche je vous communiquerai
très volontiers les chiffres je vais
demander à la direction de
l'administration pénitentiaire de me les
communiquer dès que je les ai jolie
communique mais ne laissons pas entendre
s'il vous plaît que le quartier
disciplinaire autrement appelé mitter
serait le lieu de l'arbitraire absolu je
rappelle que
détenus quand il est envoyé au mitard
comparé devant une commission composée
du directeur de l'établissement
pénitentiaire d'un assesseur qui vient
de la société civile qu'il peut être
défendu par un avocat
naturellement nous avons évoqué ici au
Sénat c'est le président François Noël
buffet qui est à l'initiative de cette
proposition de loi sur les conditions
indignes les conditions indignes elles
touchent la détention ordinaire comme
naturellement les quartiers
disciplinaires et nous y sommes
particulièrement sensible je veux à ce
titre vous indiquez que nous avons
consacré plus de 130 millions d'euros
par an pour la rénovation mais les
choses ne se font pas en un claquement
de doigts j'ai déjà eu hélas l'honneur
et le déplaisir en même temps de le dire
la justice c'est un abandon
de trois décennies sur le plan humain
sur le plan budgétaire et sur le plan
politique par ailleurs s'agissant des
suicides évidemment que le quartier
disciplinaire peut être un facteur
favorisant si j'ose dire nous y sommes
très attentifs le personnel
pénitentiaire
prendre un certain nombre de
dispositions nous faisons venir des
médecins également pour que on s'occupe
davantage des détenus tout cela est en
cohérence parce que vous avez bien
compris que le suicide de détenu c'est
un échec je vous ouvre la porte de la
Chancellerie je vous communique les
chiffres monsieur le sénateur très
prochainement et nous réfléchirons
ensemble à ce que vous avez évoqué mais
je le dis ça n'est pas pour le moment à
l'ordre du jour
vous avez quelques secondes
[Applaudissements]
je remercie monsieur le ministre je
voulais juste signaler que quelques fois
certains processus administratifs
peuvent créer des problèmes par exemple
le passage en quartier disciplinaire de
détenus parce qu'il possède des
portables qui ne sont pas ceux qui sont
bien disposition par administration et
on sait que les contrats les marchés
d'état de l'administration faut que ces
portables leur coup de communication
coûtent 10 fois plus cher que net
n'importe lequel d'entre nous le coût
d'une communication normale donc il y a
aussi un certain nombre de mesures à
prendre y compris dans les marchés qui
sont passés aujourd'hui par l'État
albinister pour ces matériels
la parole est à notre collègue lors
d'Arcos pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de
l'insertion monsieur le ministre le
gouvernement vient de présenter sa
réforme des retraites et le moins que
l'on puisse dire et que les femmes
pourraient être les grandes perdantes
des mesures à venir
l'étude d'impact le démontre clairement
elles devront travailler en moyenne 7
mois de plus alors que les hommes ne
seront astrins qu'à 5 mois
supplémentaires en outre de nombreuses
femmes pouvaient partir dès 62 ans à
taux plein grâce au trimestre à qui lors
de la naissance de leurs enfants avec
votre réforme elles devront travailler
deux ans de plus pour atteindre le
nouvel âge légal de 64 ans et perdront
le bénéfice de cette bonification vous
aurez beau jeu de souligner qu'en
travaillant plus longtemps et
bénéficieront d'une retraite de
revaloriser vous ne manquerez pas de
rappeler également quels seront les
premières bénéficiaires de la hausse au
minimum de la pension du minimum de
pension mais de quelle retraite
parlons-nous vous n'ignorez pas que la
retraite des femmes est de 5% inférieur
à celle des hommes parce qu'elles sont
les premières victimes des inégalités
salariales vous ne pouvez ignorer non
plus qu'elles ont des carrières
fréquemment interrompues par des
maternités qui réduisent la durée de
cotisation et font d'elle les plus
touchées par la décote dans ces
conditions il est indispensable de
compenser les forces supplémentaires
demandées aux femmes de mieux en prendre
en compte leur maternité car une réforme
des retraites par répartition ne peut se
désintéresser de la politique familiale
et d'avancer l'âge de la décote à ce
stade du projet loi et avant les
discussions parlementaires ces mesures
nous paraissent plus équitables que
l'allongement de la durée de vie active
pour améliorer le taux de pension
êtes-vous prêt monsieur le ministre à
corriger ces injustices qui concernent
les femmes et que notre groupe a déjà
pointé à plusieurs reprises sur un sujet
aussi grave nous aurons à cœur de
trouver dans la majorité sénatoriale
comme un autre habitude une solution de
compromis acceptable par tous je vous
remercie pour votre réponse
monsieur le ministre du Travail plein
d'emploi de l'insertion je vous donne la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice darkos d'abord vous
avez raison sur un point en particulier
qui est je crois fondamental dans les
bases sur les retraites et sur les
inégalités de niveau de retraite entre
les femmes et les hommes aujourd'hui 50
% des femmes retraitées une retraite
inférieure à 1000 euros brut parce que
c'est la conséquence l'effet miroir
d'une inégalité face au travail d'une
égalité face au salaire et ce mouvement
sociologique que nous connaissons
d'augmentation du taux d'activité
d'augmentation du taux d'emploi des
femmes corrige petit à petit et bien
trop lentement cette inégalité qui est
simplement le fruit des inégalités
professionnelles et de carrière c'est là
peut-être la priorité rétablir l'égalité
professionnelle pour que nous n'ayons
pas au moment des départs à la retraite
à imaginer à penser des systèmes de
retraite qui soit en réalité des
systèmes qui viennent corriger des
inégalités accumulées tout au long de la
vie nous avons dans le projet qu'elle
notre un effort qui est demandé à tous
les salariés
quel que soit leur cadre d'emploi quel
que soit leur corps d'emploi public
Régine spéciaux nous savons que le
départ effectif là je n'ai pas effectif
des femmes va se rapprocher de celui des
hommes même si je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure l'âge moyen de départ des femmes
restera inférieure à celui des hommes
nous avons voulu apporter des
corrections et des protections j'ai
évoqué la question de la retraite
minimum vous l'avez fait vous-même je
pourrais évoquer par exemple ou
réévoquer le fait que nous allons
intégrer dans les trimestres prises en
compte les trimestres cotisés au titre
de l'assurance vieillesse pour les
parents au foyer cela concerne un
million 900 000 femmes notamment parmi
les moins favorisés tant pour les
éligibilité au minimum de pension que
pour les éligibilité au départ anticipé
pour carrière longue nous avons
certainement encore du travail à faire
autour de la question des aidants nous
allons créer cette assurance vieillesse
pour les aidants ce sont souvent des
femmes nous avons aussi un travail à
faire pour harmoniser les droits comment
expliquer qu'aujourd'hui une maternité
soit génératrice si je puis dire de 4
trimestres de manière automatique au
titre du régime général et de deux au
titre de la fonction publique nous avons
d'ores et déjà demandé avec madame la
Première ministre au Conseil
d'orientation des retraites un chantier
sur ce sujet là et j'espère que les
débats parlementaires nous permettra
d'avancer sur cette question des droits
familiaux sur cette question de la
parentalité de la maternité mais aussi
sur les questions de reversion le texte
celle qu'il sera adopté je l'espère par
l'Assemblée nationale nous permettra
certainement de construire des consensus
bonhomme darkos
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur ministre j'entends ce que
vous dites et en effet
vous allez déjà revaloriser en effet les
plus les plus retraite mais on voudrait
pouvoir également parler au nom de
toutes ces femmes qui travaillent depuis
longtemps qui ont des beaux Jobs et qui
ont eu des moments aussi formidables de
d'arrêt avec avec leurs congés maternité
donc de toutes les secteurs d'activité
je parle aussi bien évidemment des des
femmes dans le milieu de l'agriculture
la délégation a fait déjà beaucoup dans
d'autres dans plein de secteurs et donc
je vous inviterai avec le secrétaire de
Madame Rome à pouvoir regarder nos
rapports et nos projets pour pouvoir
également construire la fin de ce projet
de loi sur les retraites tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
meunier pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste hérétique
[Applaudissements]
le président du Sénat madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres chers collègues il y a un an
quasiment jour pour jour paraissait les
fossoyeur le livre de Victor Castanet
sur le système ORPEA chacun a salué
l'enquête minutieuse et le prix Albert
Londres est bien mérité mais maintenant
les dysfonctionnements sont connus les
sanctions sont prononcées les EHPAD
lucratifs doivent être mieux encadrés
puisqu'il prospère du fruit des
cotisations et de la solidarité
nationale le Sénat ici à proposer de
renforcer le contrôle des EHPAD et si
nous avons modifié ce cadre législatif
sur le terrain les moyens humains
restent lacunaire distant sur pièce
comptable bien loin de nos
recommandations pour des inspections
contrôles coordonnées dès lors les
questions subsistent monsieur le
ministre de l'autonomie entendez-vous
nos concitoyens et nos concitoyens qui
espèrent plus d'attention et de soins
pour leur aînés
entendez-vous les familles révoltées à
juste titre des maltraitances parfois
infligées à leurs proches entendez-vous
l'alerte de la Défenseur des droits et
surtout monsieur le ministre prenez-vous
la mesure de l'attente des soignants et
des soignants qui disent nous devons
être plus nombreuses pour mieux
travailler pour cesser de nous éreinter
et pour éviter d'être inapte à l'heure
de la retraite
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste des solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
monsieur Jean-Christophe combe
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices mais c'est le sénateur madame
la sénatrice Michel meunier vous l'avez
rappelé il y a un an sortait l'enquête
approfondie de Victor Castanet qui a
produit une onde de choc dans notre
société à l'époque j'étais moi-même
gestionnaire dans une association
gestionnaire d'établissements
médico-sociaux et j'ai été profondément
choqué par l'ensemble de ces révélations
depuis lors je n'ai eu de cesse que de
m'engager pour ramener la confiance de
nos sites de nos citoyens dans les EHPAD
et protéger les personnes âgées on rôle
aujourd'hui en tant que ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées c'est de faire en
sorte de poser un cadre de réguler un
secteur et de faire en sorte que ce
cadre soit respecté et je le dis de
façon très claire et de façon très ferme
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui pensent
pouvoir se décharger de leur
responsabilité en Atta dans l'état
commettent une double faute la première
c'est qu'il manque aux Français c'est
que ils ne disent pas la vérité et la
seconde c'est qu'à l'époque ils n'ont
pas été à la hauteur et qu'ils ne le
sont toujours pas aujourd'hui
malheureusement et la vérité c'est que
l'État et les premiers jours de ses
révélations agit de façon extrêmement
puissante en lançant une vague de
contrôle inédite avant tous les 20 ans
ces établissements étaient contrôlés on
va les contrôler maintenant tous les
deux ans 1400 établissements sur les
7500 ont d'ores et déjà été contrôlés
700 ont fait l'objet d'inspection
contrôle grâce au recrutement de 120
contrôleur supplémentaires dans les ARS
et je salue le travail approfondi des
ARS pour faire en sorte que ça ne se
reproduise pas le deuxième élément que
je voulais soulever c'est celui du tabou
de la maltraitance contre les personnes
adultes vulnérables il faut lever tabou
libérer la parole je lancerai dans
quelques jours une plateforme de recueil
des signalements pour pouvoir libérer
cette les paroles et des états généraux
de la maltraitance auront lieu dans
quelques semaines et qui réuniront
l'ensemble des acteurs police justice
famille personne concernées et puis
enfin c'est le travail que nous
conduisons pour transformer le secteur 9
milliards d'euros en 5 ans seront
investis pour transformer l'offre
médico-sociale
merci
Madame
le Ministre
de ce modèle marchant qui ne peut
rémunérer des actionnaires que s'il
s'occupe mal des personnes âgées si
c'est le cas vous trouverez sur nos
bancs ici au Sénat des soutiens pour y
mettre fin et ça passera par l'examen
d'une loi grand âge elle consacrera
cette loi des moyens humains renforcée
et des financements pérennes et il faut
fléchir une partie de la richesse créée
dans notre pays vers la prise en charge
des personnes en perte de l'autonomie
mais les Françaises et les Français ne
souhaitent pas que cet effort consolide
la cotisation la cotation pardon
boursière des grands groupes d'EHPAD et
viennent dans les poches du CAC 40
[Applaudissements]
la parole de notre collègue Valérie
Boyer pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le ministre j'associe mon
collègue Laurent saumon à ma question il
y a trois mois alors que le
vice-président du Sénat Roger carochi
vous interrogez sur le rapatriement des
femmes et des enfants de djihadistes
vous allez répondu je vous cite en
réalité notre doctrine n'a pas changé
ironie ou mépris en effet depuis 2009
c'était le cas par cas pour les enfants
dans une logique purement humanitaire et
la tolérance zéro pour les femmes et je
ne veux employer le terme rapatriement
car il s'agit de revenante nous
apprenons par la presse que 15 femmes et
32 enfants sont revenus sans compter les
31 femmes et les 67 enfants l'année
dernière
assumez-vous ce changement de doctrine
c'est-à-dire l'abandon du cas par cas et
ses retours massifs comment assurez-vous
la prise en charge de ces enfants par
les services de l'aseu déjà au bord de
la fixie comme l'enfermement de ces
femmes dans nos prisons déjà saturées et
qui sont considérés parfois comme des
héroïnes comment pouvez-vous garantir la
sécurité des Français face à ces
personnes qui haïssent toujours la
France
pour vous répondre la parole
est au garde des sceaux ministres de la
Justice monsieur Dupont-Moretti monsieur
le Président du Sénat mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice Boyer
ni ironie ni prix votre champ lexical
aurait peut-être pu vous permettre
d'envisager d'autres choses nous n'avons
pas changé la position du gouvernement
est extrêmement claire et elle est
précise ceux qui ont choisi daesh
doivent être jugés au plus près des
lieux où ils ont commis leur crime mais
mais ça n'est pas un petit mais il y a
des enfants madame la sénatrice oui qui
n'ont rien choisi et qui doivent être
traités avec humanité et vigilance
humanité parce que ce sont des enfants
et j'ajoute des enfants français ne vous
en déplaise
et vigilance parce que ils sont
susceptiblement
susceptiblement possiblement d'être
traumatisé à vie avec toutes les
séquelles que cela peut-on engendrer
alors non nous n'avons pas changé nous
rapatrions à la demande chaque fois que
cela est possible des femmes qui le
demandent avec des enfants en ayant
naturellement à l'esprit la sécurité de
nos forces de l'ordre qui se trouvent
sur place parce que nous ne maîtrisons
pas tout les femmes ont toutes fait
l'objet d'une judiciarisation
quant aux enfants ils sont placés
parfois auprès de leurs grands-parents
qui sont des gens parfaitement intégrés
parfaitement honnêtes et je le redis
parfaitement français madame la
sénatrice voilà les enfants font l'objet
d'un suivi sanitaire d'un suivi médical
d'un suivi psychologique fermeté pour
les femmes humanité vigilance pour les
enfants on pourrait tomber d'accord
là-dessus ça n'est ni de l'ironie ni du
mépris
madame Boyer
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre
l'humanité vous n'en avez pas le
monopole et personne ici ne peut nier
que nous aussi nous souhaitons traiter
les enfants en revanche en revanche la
doctrine du cas par cas avait été
adoptée par vos prétesseurs monsieur
LeDrian et Madame beloubet qu'en est-il
aujourd'hui pourquoi changer vous de
doctrine en opendant désormais pour des
migrations mortifères massives le
président Macron le président Macron
lui-même considérait que ses retours
étaient trop dangereux pour la sécurité
des Français qu'en est-il aujourd'hui
des personnes qui restent combien
sont-elles vous injecter dans la
population française des djihadistes
alors que notre pays est déjà gangrené
par le salafisme n'oublions pas
n'oublions pas que la France
avec 1400 individus et le premier pays
européen et le deuxième pays au monde à
avoir fourni des terroristes à l'état
islamiste avec des femmes qui se sont
engagées pour aller combattre en Syrie
et en Irak contre la France aujourd'hui
avons-nous les moyens d'une telle
politique merci
[Applaudissements]
et donner la parole à madame la
Présidente Valérie l'Etat pour le groupe
de l'Union de santé
[Applaudissements]
personne ne peut ignorer ce fléau
l'usage détourné du protoxyde d'azote
explose en France située à la troisième
place des produits psychoactifs les plus
utilisés notamment chez les jeunes
adultes son caractère addictif est
aujourd'hui scientifiquement avéré le
nombre de cas évalués par les réseaux
des centres de pharmacovigilance qui
sont les cas les plus sévères et qui
donnent souvent lui à une
hospitalisation a été multipliée par 10
en 3 ans et ce n'est que ça s'émerger de
l'iceberg jour après jour les autorités
sanitaires découvrent de nouvelles
complications suite à cette consommation
massive et inédite ces cas bien plus
grave que d'autres produits qualifiés
comme stupéfiants c'est cas révèle des
symptômes psychiatriques anxiété
psychose ou autre troubles du
comportement mais aussi des conséquences
lourdes sur la sensibilité la motricité
avec des séquelles parfois irréversibles
pouvant aller jusqu'à une sclérose
combinée de la moelle épinière face à ce
fléau à cette drogue qui ne porte pas
son nom
adopter en juin 2021 une première
initiative parlementaire pour revenir
pour prévenir et encadrer cette
consommation détournée avec le soutien
de tous nos collègues monsieur le
ministre si je vous interpelle
aujourd'hui c'est parce que les décrets
d'application de ce texte visant à
limiter la quantité de vente de
cartouches de protoxyde mais surtout
interdire la vente de bonbonne à des
particuliers devaient être sorti depuis
plus de huit mois après avoir alerté
votre ministère sur ses retards dès
septembre dernier il m'a été assuré une
publication fin 2022 pourquoi ces
décrets ne sont-ils toujours pas pris
quand on sait que les bonbonnes
accélèrent fortement la consommation
excessive et régulière de ce de ce
protoxyde dont les conséquences et sont
lots de séquelles sont quand même
énormes c'est grave monsieur le ministre
et d'ailleurs à quand une véritable
campagne d'information et de prévention
nationale attendue face à ce phénomène
toujours croissant et interpellé par les
acteurs de terrain professionnels de
santé magistrat élu démunies j'ai déposé
un second texte visant délictualiser la
consommation de protoxyde d'azote et à
poursuivre les personnes qui conduit sur
son emprise car c'est extrêmement
accidentogène que ça peut donner un
énorme problème monsieur
le dire de ce sujet
pour vous répondre la parole est à mes
chemises de la santé de la prévention
monsieur Braun résident mesdames et
messieurs et sénateurs madame la
sénatrice l'étage je vous rejoins le MES
usages du protoxyde d'azote et un
problème de santé publique qui touche
principalement les plus jeunes puisque
plus de 5% des enfants au collège en
3ème déclare avoir déjà utilisé ce
protoxyde d'azote à des fins récréatives
alors il y a deux axes un axe prévention
un axe sanction comme le test que vous
avez porté concernant la prévention tout
d'abord la connaissance du produit vous
le dit très bien on améliore nos
connaissances sur ce produit sur sa
toxicité c'est un produit qui est connu
depuis longtemps qui est utilisé en
fonction de 100 pourcentage par rapport
à l'oxygène soit comme un gaz
anesthésique soit comme un gaz
antalgique soi-même comme un gaz
hilarant ces nouvelles toxicités que
l'on découvre elle touche effectivement
le système nerveux central mais il faut
pas oublier une toxicité immédiate en
cas d'asphyxie qui est particulièrement
dangereuse l'information est de faire de
lance nous remontons les informations au
niveau national maintenant région par
région ça nous a permis en particulier
dans votre région d'avoir une campagne
d'information très ciblée envers les
jeunes entre 15 et 25 ans en utilisant
les réseaux sociaux et nous allons
continuer dans cette voie en ce qui
concerne la loi que vous avez portée
l'année dernière plusieurs applications
de cette loi sont déjà en cours que cela
concerne l'interdiction de vente aux
mineurs l'interdiction de vendre dans
les débits de boissons l'interdiction de
vendre des crackers qui sont ces
dispositifs qui permettent justement ce
MES usages tout comme la création d'un
délit pour des personnes majeures qui
pousseraient des jeunes à l'utiliser en
ce qui concerne le sud de votre projet
de loi comme vous le savez cela était
notifié à la Commission européenne en
février dernier la commission est le
ministère ont fait plusieurs
allers-retours un des créer un arrêté
sont en cours de publication j'espère
avant la fin du mois de février le
décret concerne les informations sur les
boîtes et sur les chez lui elle arrêtait
concerne la limitation de vente de 10
capsules maximum par personne nous
sommes mobilisés face à ce problème de
santé publique nous accélérons avec la
Commission européenne pour pouvoir
publier ces textes au plus vite
merci la parole de notre collègue Pierre
Cuypers pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voudrais associer à cette
question la sénatrice Christina pluschet
jeudi 19 janvier jour funeste pour
l'agriculture française la Cour de
justice européenne décide de rendre
illégal les dérogations prévues pour la
filière betteravière sur l'utilisation
des néonicotinoïdes le 30 octobre 2020
votre prédécesseur affirmé avec justesse
que la situation était perduement grave
et que tout devait être mis en oeuvre
pour protéger cette filière de même le
président de la République affirmait
haut et fort qu'il ne devait pas y avoir
d'interdit sans solution vous-même
monsieur le ministre vous m'affirmiez le
12 janvier être certain de la
reconduction des dérogations prévues
pour 2023 de plus en 2016 la France a
interdit l'usage de tous les néons
nicotinoïdes en aspersion ou en enrobage
de semences ce que l'Allemagne et tous
les autres pays s'autorisent la France
est mise dans l'impasse en 2020 la
catastrophe de la jeunesse de la
betterave avait occasionné 200 millions
de pertes malgré les engagements pris
l'indemnisation n'a été que de 10 à 30 %
du préjudice notre souveraineté
alimentaire et énergétique et donc
menacée quelle réponse concrètes le
gouvernement entend apporter à cette
situation et à cette crise latente
monsieur le ministre il vous reste moins
de 10 jours pour apporter toutes les
solutions qui s'imposent car les
agriculteurs doivent prévoir leur semis
pour vous répondre la parole autobilise
d'agriculture et de souveraineté
alimentaire Monsieur fenaud Merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
QWERTZ vous connaissez très bien cette
question et je vous remercie avec cette
question de pouvoir essayer d'éclairer
le débat vous avez raison il y a une
décision de la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne qui s'impose à tous
elle vient contrecarrer disons-le un
plan qui était celui sur 3 ans de sortir
des néonicotinoïdes en la forme
autorisant la dérogation sur les
semences enrobées et en permettant de
déployer des solutions alternatives et
le programme était pour la troisième
année en cours cette décision s'impose à
nous tous vous avez raison on a très peu
de temps pour agir pour assurer les
planteurs vous l'avez dit aussi d'une
certaine façon pour assurer aussi
l'ensemble de la filière je pense aux
industrie qui triture la betterave et
qui sont importantes en particulier dans
votre département dans mais dans
beaucoup de départements de France
première élément garantir aux
agriculteurs qui seront couverts sur la
sur la perte de jaunisse on est en train
d'y travailler mais c'est bien ça sur
lequel on doit être au rendez-vous sur
la sous les jours qui viennent pour les
assurer qui pourront planter dans des
conditions qui soient des conditions
d'amortissement deuxièmement accélérer
encore
la recherche de solutions alternatives
soit dans celle qui était dans le plan
national de recherche je rappelle qu'on
avait mis plus de 20 millions d'euros
entre les acteurs de la filière et
l'État au travers de recherche que
melindra et qu'on travaille avec ma
collègue Retailleau et puis deuxième
élément d'essayer de travailler sur
d'autres recherches et d'autres
itinérateurs techniques avec des
molécules qui sont encore autorisées
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on expertise très
vite pour regarder les solutions pour le
coup en foliaire qui pourrait être
expertisé troisième élément vous avez
raison monsieur le sénateur je maintiens
ce qu'a dit mon prédécesseur ce qui a
dit le président de la République et ce
que j'ai dit par l'interdiction sans
solution la vérité c'est que cette
interdiction elle procède de 2016 le
principe de précaution à la charge de
l'environnement et d'être là de bien
avant donc il faut qu'on assume aussi
les décisions qui ont été prises c'est
difficile pour tout le monde y compris
pour le ministre de l'Agriculture c'est
difficile surtout pour les betteraviers
moi mon sujet c'est de leur donner de la
visibilité la visibilité c'est le plan
de soutien sur la jaunisse et c'est
d'associer aussi les transformateurs
pour faire en sorte que ils bénéficie
des betteraves dont ils ont besoin pour
faire tourner les outils de production
nous allons y travailler dans les jours
qui viennent nous nous sommes déjà à
l'oeuvre je récupère
je connaissais votre réponse mais il
faut des solutions et des certitudes
parce qu'au-delà de la compréhension
au-delà de l'impuissance française c'est
la colère c'est le désarroi c'est le feu
dans nos territoires c'est le saccage
annoncé de nos filières c'est la mise en
péril de l'industrie de sucre de
l'alcool du bioéthanol du gel
hydroalcoolique de l'alimentation
animale c'est le risque d'importation
massive de sucre ou d'éthanol notamment
du Brésil qui est produit avec des
produits que nous refusons ici en France
cet obéir c'est opéré la souveraineté
alimentaire et énergétique la France
devient le seul pays au monde à tous ces
interdits
la parole est à notre collègue
Usain Bourvil pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Madame la première ministre mesdames
Messieurs les gouvernement mesdames
Messieurs chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
cela fait 4 mois que l'Iran connaît un
mouvement citoyen inédit afin de
dénoncer le régime théocratique ces
violations des droits fondamentaux et
des libertés publiques comme vous le
savez ce mouvement est né au lendemain
de la mort de
Massa mini accusé de ne pas avoir porté
correctement son voile depuis ce sont
surtout des femmes et des hommes qui
sont à la pointe de cette mobilisation
en retour la répression du régime est
implacable des milliers d'arrestations
500 morts des simulacres de procès des
exécutions sommaires
persécutées par le régime iranien des
opposants fuient l'Iran et trouve refuge
pour certains en France
c'est le cas de Farid et une Iranienne
de 38 ans interpellé la semaine dernière
par la police aux frontières à
l'aéroport de Chambéry alors qu'elle
souhaitait se rendre en Angleterre pour
rejoindre son mari réfugié là-bas elle
fit ensuite transféré au centre de
rétention administrative de Toulouse
enfermé pendant 48 heures avant d'être
libéré pendant que la préfecture prenait
une obligation de quitter le territoire
français et contacter les services
consulaires iraniens en France afin
d'envisager sa reconduite à la frontière
comme c'est le cas et comme c'est
l'usage à chaque fois qu'une obligation
de quitter le territoire est prise
cela nous interpelle cela nous interroge
parce que la France à l'instar des
autres pays occidentaux par la voie du
président de la République de plusieurs
ministres ici présents a condamné à la
répression en œuvre en Iran et apporter
son soutien aux manifestants monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur pouvez-vous nous
préciser la doctrine de la France à
l'égard des opposants au régime iranien
présent notre pays qu'ils soient en
situation régulière ou irrégulière pour
vous répondre la parole et comme je t'ai
mis l'intérieur les autres mères
monsieur Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur
la citoyenne d'iranienne que vous
évoquez a été interpellé quatre fois sur
le sol national et lors de sa première
interpellation lorsque les services de
la police ont constatés qu'elle était
par régulièrement ce territoire national
et qu'elle se disait tyrannienne il
fallait évidemment vérifier son identité
et c'est pour cela que nous consultons
les services consulaires de tous les
pays c'est le cas évidemment pour l'Iran
avec nous avons encore des relations
diplomatiques pour identifier des
personnes afin qu'elles ne se fasse pas
passer pour une autre personne une fois
que nous avons constaté en effet qui a
été tiranienne nous l'avons libéré comme
vous l'avez très bien dit du centre de
rétention c'est l'État qui l'a fait et
ce n'est pas un jugement administratif
vous avez oublié de le mettre vous avez
oublié pardon de le dire et deuxièmement
nous lui avons encouragé nous l'avons
encouragé à prendre des rendez-vous pour
pouvoir demander l'asile dans notre pays
ou un titre d'un jour afin de
régulariser sa situation elle ne l'a
jamais fait
après ce premier contrôle trois autres
contrôles ont été constatés par la
police frontières la République ne peut
pas accepter quelqu'un qui est
irrégulièrement sur le territoire
national c'est une personne ne veut pas
rester en France elle ne veut pas
demander l'asile en France elle ne veut
pas de titre de séjour en France nous
l'aurions accueilli évidemment mais elle
veut rejoindre comme vous l'avez dit sa
famille qui est en Angleterre il ne
s'agit donc pas pour la France de
ramener vers l'Iran des ressortissants
nous ne ramenons plus évidemment vers
l'Iran des ressortissants nous
identifions les personnes s'ils ne
veulent pas rester sur notre sol on va
pas leur donner des papiers de force
avouer bien volontiers les choses et
nous avons contacté le Royaume-Uni pour
qu'elle puisse se rapprocher de sa
famille nous avons encore reçu réponse
de la part du gouvernement britannique
mais je veux ici vous assurer que
d'excuseront personne est encore moins
la personne que vous évoquez en Iran
nous leur réinvitons et si vous avez
contacté avec elle je vous demande de le
faire si elle le souhaite de déposer un
dossier de mandatile en France nous
étudierons évidemment avec rapidité et
avec humanité
je vous remercie pour la réponse mais
comme vous le savez son mari est en
Angleterre c'est là-bas qu'elle compte
faire ses démarches je voulais vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre que l'histoire de
notre pays elle est grande elle est
belle elle nous donne chaque jour à
chacun à chacune d'entre nous des motifs
légitimes d'en tirer une fierté
particulière parfois elle connaît des
zones d'ombre cette histoire de France
lorsque nous n'avons pas su ou pas voulu
apporter la protection nécessaire à ceux
qui travaillent pour l'armée française
en Afghanistan les fixeurs les grilles
les traducteurs je vous demande monsieur
le ministre et je m'adresse à vous en
tant que ministre mais je m'adresse
surtout à votre conscience à veiller à
ce que les 50 Iraniens qui sont
aujourd'hui sous le coup de nos qtf ne
soit pas renvoyé dans leur pays quand
vous connaissez très bien le sort qui
pourrait leur être réservé je parle de
cette dame mais je parle beaucoup
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
Pacaud pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre dans le
calendrier révolutionnaire nous sommes
en pluvios c'est le mois de la pluie et
il pleut des annonces de fermeture de
classe partout dans le pays surtout en
zone rurale alors avec 59 milliards de
budget 6 et demi pour cent de haut on ne
peut que déplorer ces coupes sombres
2000 postes en moins certes la
démographie scolaire connaît une baisse
continue certes cette revalorisation
enfin ce budget conséquent permettra une
revalorisation indispensable des
rémunérations des enseignants mais alors
que tous les classements internationaux
toutes les évaluations nationales alerte
sur la fragilisation de du niveau global
des élèves alors que vous vantez les
vertus des effectifs réduits la base est
doublée où est la cohérence pédagogique
et surtout où est la justice
territoriale quand à quelques kilomètres
quelques hectomètres parfois ici on va
fermer une classe parce qu'avec 22
gamins ils sont trop nombreux et à côté
on va se réjouir d'avoir 12 gamins dans
une classe dédoublée pour plus
d'efficacité je le rappelle 70% des
élèves qui relèvent de l'éducation
prioritaire se trouve en zone rurale ou
dans des quartiers qui ne sont pas
concernés monsieur le ministre ma
question elle est simple la ruralité
est-elle devenue la variable
d'ajustement de vos politiques
éducatives
pour vous répondre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est communiste de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse j'ai pas fait
de la
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Paco vous l'avez dit la
démographie scolaire connaît une baisse
importante depuis plusieurs années une
belle ce qui va à s'accentuer au rythme
de 90 000 à 100 000 élèves de moins
chaque année nous prévoyons une baisse
donc de d'environ 500 000 élèves d'ici à
la fin du quinquennat dans votre
département de l'Oise par exemple ce
sont
1367 élèves que l'on va compter en moins
à la prochaine rentrée dans ce contexte
de baisse démographique le taux
d'encadrement c'est-à-dire le ratio
entre professeur et élèves s'améliorent
depuis plusieurs années il va continuer
à s'améliorer par exemple dans l'Oise il
y a en moyenne
21,5% 21,5 élèves par classe et cette
moyenne va s'améliorer légèrement
l'année prochaine nous avons créé ces
dernières années sans deux postes de
professeurs dans l'Oise pour une baisse
de
6631 élèves dans le budget 2023 nous
avons comme vous l'avez dit donner la
priorité à la revalorisation des
professeurs parce que monsieur le
sénateur à quoi sert-il de créer des
postes si nous ne pouvons pas pourvoir
les postes la question est donc d'abord
de pourvoir les postes que nous créons
avant de les multiplier sans que cela
est un effet sur le terrain quant aux
fermetures que vous évoquez nous ne le
faisons pas de manière arithmétique bien
au contraire dans chaque département les
dazaines sont au début du processus de
préparation de la rentrée 2023 avec les
élus locaux ils travaillent pour
identifier les situations sensibles et
je suis particulièrement sensible
moi-même à la situation des zones
rurales et des écoles rurales de manière
à faire des ajustements en juin et
également en août à la fin août à ce
stade rien n'est définitivement arrêté
et je serai heureux d'en reparler avec
vous
monsieur Paco oui merci d'avoir juste à
la fin
évoquer la ruralité parce que un des
gros problèmes de l'éducation nationale
mais même des politiques publiques
depuis des années c'est l'oubli de ces
territoires en 1947 Jean-François
gravier publié Paris et le désert
français depuis 2017 Emmanuel Macron
décline les métropoles et le désert
français la France c'est sans un
département 35000 communes 68 millions
d'habitants et la République c'est aussi
et surtout l'égalité des droits et des
chances partout et pour tous
merci
la parole est
notre collègue Laurent Duplomb pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
je m'adresse à tous les ministres tant
le sujet nous concerne tous
savez-vous que la présidente de la
Commission européenne a autorisé le 3
janvier dernier un nouvel aliment
savez-vous que ce nouvel aliment est une
farine partiellement dégraissée
incorporez dans de multiples recettes
savez-vous que depuis hier vous pouvez
trouver cette farine sans informations
claire du consommateur dans les pins
biscuits sauce plat transformée pizza
confiserie ou pâtes et j'en passe et des
meilleurs enfin installez-vous que cette
farine partiellement dégraissée est
faite avec des achats domesticus entiers
broyés en poudre alors madame et
messieurs mesdames et messieurs les
ministres savez-vous ce qu'est
l'acheteur domesticus
de la parole est au ministre
d'agriculture de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur fenaud
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs oui monsieur le
sénateur je crois que c'est un insecte
et donc c'est bien la question vous
voulez poser c'est de savoir d'abord
pour dire que pardon de vous le dire il
n'est pas nouveau y compris dans depuis
très longtemps que dans un certain
nombre de pays on puisse se nourrir
d'insectes ce n'est pas en soi on peut
avoir des goûts différents moins compris
mais c'est une réalité deuxième élément
ça participe tout à fait d'une
réglementation européenne qui a été
autorisée simplement la réglementation
européenne néglige monsieur le sénateur
c'est qu'on mentionne la nature du
produit en l'occurrence pour ce cet
insecte la question de l'allergénéité
des uns et des autres donc il faut qu'on
soit vigilant sur la mention dans les
produits qui sont dans disant qu'il y a
un produit qui peut être allergène en
l'occurrence cet insecte troisième
élément on travaille au niveau européen
globalement essayer d'harmoniser les
choses et c'est mieux que ça soit au
niveau européen que chaque pays décide
de commercialiser telle ou tel autre et
donc c'est ça sur lequel on a besoin de
travailler ça nécessite aussi et nous
avons besoin de continuer à renforcer à
nos frontières européennes mais aussi au
niveau national la surveillance
sanitaire parce qu'il y a toujours des
gens qui essayent de déroger aurait que
nous nous fixons au niveau européen ça
existe dans le sujet agricole et
sanitaire comme dans le bien d'autres
sujets donc il faut qu'on y travaille
qu'on continue à avancer mais
reconnaissons les mesures qui sont
prises elles vivent plutôt à protéger à
informer le consommateur à protéger le
cas échéché en l'environnement et donc
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on
travaille sans travailler sur des
questions de distension de concurrence
ça me permet un dernier mot monsieur le
sénateur il me semble que sur ces sujets
il faut qu'on travaille justement au
niveau européen rien ne s'épuise on en a
parlé dans un autre exemple tout à
l'heure que d'avoir des dispositions qui
s'appliquent simplement sur le sol
français qui ne s'applique pas au niveau
européen donc la bataille elle est
d'abord européenne et c'est là-dessus
qu'il faut qu'on continue à travailler
monsieur Duplomb
monsieur le ministre comment en
sommes-nous arrivés là à devoir
consommer des grillons de la même
famille que les sauterelles ou les
criquets alors que la France est le pays
de la gastronomie et des terroirs
comment pouvez-vous laisser faire cela
alors que vous n'avez de cesse de nous
parler d'une alimentation saine et
durable d'agroécologie et de circuits
courts scène et durable cette farine ne
l'est pas même la Commission ne garantit
pas l'absence de problèmes sanitaires
contrairement à ce que vous venez de
dire où est l'agroécologie avec
l'élevage hors sol de millions de
grillons dans des bâtiments industriels
et que dire des circuits courts alors
que cette poudre de Grillon est importée
du Vietnam cette Commission européenne
qui cède au lobby antiviande et qui sape
notre agriculture et notre culture
gastronomique je n'en veux plus
soutenant plutôt la farine de blé plutôt
que la farine de Grillon soutenant le
sucre français plutôt que les insectes
d'Asie nous ne pouvons pas accepter de
faire manger à leur insu des insectes
aux Français ceux qui souhaitent manger
des grillons monsieur le ministre je les
invite à venir les manger directement
dans mes prés ils seront nature entier
nombreux et non transformés et pour tous
les autres je leur conseille de
constituer que de continuer à manger une
bonne côte de bœuf
mes chers collègues
après chers recommandation gastronomique
je vous rappelle et là c'est une annonce
particulièrement importante que mercredi
1er février à 14h30 nous recevrons
monsieur Rousselin Stephen Chuck
président de la Rada d'Ukraine dans
notre émission et qui s'exprimera je
compte particulièrement sur la présence
de chacune et de chacun
l'accord avec le gouvernement les
questions d'actualité débuteront donc à
titre exceptionnel avec 15 minutes de
décalage donc à 15h15
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
ce sera reprise à 16h30 pour l'examen de
trois conventions internationales puis
pour la suite de l'examen du projet de
loi relatif aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympique de 2024 la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement du Sénat que
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur notre antenne et on
tiendra parmi les temps forts cette
semaine ces quatre questions consacrées
à la réforme des retraites dont 3
spécifiquement sur la situation des
femmes le point de départ Céline
interview de Franck Riester sur Public
Sénat et lcpan c'était lundi soir le
ministre dans l'audition publique qui a
reconnu que les femmes seraient plus
impactées que les hommes par le report
de l'âge légal à la retraite à 64 ans de
quoi faire réagir les féministes au
Sénat écouté par exemple l'ancienne
ministre des Droits des Femmes là
sénatrice Laurence Rossignol
et puisqu'on parle d'effort le même jour
avec un sens du timing étonnant le
ministre Riester dans un moment de
franchise merveilleux a dit en effet
c'est très fort va demander aux femmes
un effort supplémentaire alors je dis
clairement pour ce qui est des femmes
les efforts c'est non on en fait déjà
assez comme ça tout le temps par
ailleurs il y a une chose qui est sûr
c'est qu'elles vont devoir travailler
plus longtemps et non seulement plus
longtemps mais plus longtemps que les
hommes qui vont devoir travailler plus
longtemps puisque selon les études des
experts ce sera le double d'un
allongement de la durée du travail pour
les femmes appartenait à partir de 1972
on le voit la gauche de l'hémicycle très
critique de cette réforme mais alors
c'était attendu peut-être moins le fait
que des critiques viennent des bancs de
la droite car cet aveu sur la réforme et
ses effets pour les femmes cela
interroge aussi elle est LR écoutée lors
d'un Arcos il soutiennent l'esprit de la
réforme allait à l'air mais il ne faut
pas oublier de prendre en compte la
politique familiale à dilandarkos
écouter un extrait
vous n'ignorez pas que la
retraite vous ne pouvez ignorer non plus
qu'elles ont des carrières fréquemment
interrompues par des maternités qui
réduisent la durée de cotisation et fond
d'elle les plus touchées par la décote
dans ces conditions il est indispensable
de compenser les forces supplémentaires
demandées aux femmes de mieux en prendre
en compte leur maternité car une réforme
des retraites par répartition ne peut se
désintéresser de la politique familiale
et d'avancer l'âge de la décote voilà
ces ministres du travail Olivier du soft
qui a répondu à toutes ces questions
venues des sénatrices il a inventé les
divertis positifs de la réforme qui
pourront améliorer la situation des
femmes quant au trimestre acquis à la
naissance d'un enfant pourrait-il jouer
à nouveau sur l'âge de départ écoutez la
réponse de l'ivier du soft nous avons
d'ores et déjà demandé avec madame la
Première ministre au Conseil
d'orientation des retraites d'ouvrir un
chantier sur ce sujet là et j'espère que
les débats parlementaires nous permettra
d'avancer sur cette question les droits
familiaux ça fait plaisir de la
parentalité de la maternité mais aussi
sur les questions de réversion le texte
tel qu'il sera adopté je l'espère par
l'Assemblée nationale nous permettra
certainement de construire des consensus
vous le voyez ta main cette interview de
Frank Riester lundi soir sur public
national fait grand bruit ou cette
semaine au Parlement et si le
gouvernement est bien est en difficulté
c'est parce qu'il est maintenant pris en
tenaille entre la gauche mais aussi la
droite qui est bien comme la gauche
parle d'injustice à propos des
conséquences pour les femmes de la
réforme des retraites Tam merci beaucoup
Quentin pour toutes ces explications et
on va continuer ce débrief on va se
rendre salle des conférences voir
alexandre Poussin avec le sénateur
Claude malurey le président du groupe
les indépendants qui a ouvert la séance
de questions au Gouvernement une
question portant sur l'Ukraine alors
qu'aujourd'hui l'Allemagne autorise le
transfert de Charles léopard et livreera
14 blindés à l'Ukraine où en est la
France c'était bien là la question de
Claude Manu reste à vous Alexandre
question c'était de dire est-ce que la
France est un peu en retard quand même
sur l'envoi de char français en Ukraine
alors que ça y est l'Allemagne valoriser
l'envoi de chars léopard est-ce que nous
aussi on doit prendre ce chemin oui
alors il faut pas dire que quand même
que la franchise dentaire puisque
l'annonce de l'accord allemand date d'il
y a deux ou trois heures et par
conséquent nous-mêmes avons livré mais
pour le moment des charges seulement
léger donc le problème est le savoir si
il y a deux domaines dans lesquels la
France est attendue chaque pays assez
spécificités la France a des chars
lourds les Charles Clerc et la France a
des systèmes de défense seul r les
systèmes bas qui sont extrêmement
performants pour défendre l'Ukraine
contre cette véritable massacre qui se
fait dans toutes ces villes par
conséquent ces deux sujets sur lesquels
la France peut augmenter son effort et
ma question c'était de demander à la
première indice quand est-ce qu'elle va
le faire parce que chaque jour qui passe
c'est des femmes et des enfants qui
meurent dans les débris de leur immeuble
pulvérisés c'est les soldats
Ukrainiens qui tombent parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les armes pour se défendre
devant les les milices de Wagner et les
pauvres une misère qu'ils ont envoyé au
massacres voilà voilà ma question on
fait déjà un effort mais c'est le moment
de faire un effort supplémentaire c'est
ce que font aujourd'hui tous nos amis
européens tous les alliés il faut que la
France elle aussi elle donne un coup de
rein et pour l'instant Emmanuel Macron a
temporise il dit elle envoie de Charles
l'ours des chars Leclerc n'est pas exclu
mais attention au risque d'escalade pour
vous ce n'est pas un argument ce risque
d'escalade
je comprends des arguments techniques
c'est pas évident de la logistique etc
c'est pas évident et se défaire
d'armement qui pourrait nous servir dans
d'autres opérations c'est pas évident
non plus mais le problème de l'escalade
c'est pas un argument ce qu'on ne peut
pas quand on est président de la
République dire dans ses vœux le 31
décembre aux Ukrainiens nous vous
soutiendrons jusqu'à la victoire finale
et dire il faut pas l'escalade parce que
là il y aura pas de victoire sans
escalade jusqu'à présent on a laissé
Poutine
le monopole de l'escalade chaque fois
qu'on fait quelque chose vous allez
franchir une ligne rouge et on
s'aperçoit que c'est bidon puisque
chaque fois il ne peut rien faire pour
une raison évident c'est qu'il est au
maximum comment veut-on qui réagissent
encore plus la seule possibilité de
faire plus c'est son chantage atomique
mais on sait aujourd'hui que tu inping
est maudit à saint-marcande lui ont
interdit de se servir de l'arme atomique
il était d'ailleurs piteux et
c'est donc un chandel qui ne marche pas
atomique non c'est pas cet escalade là
mais n'aura pas lieu donc soit on veut
la victoire soit on veut pas l'escalade
mais on peut pas vouloir les deux à la
fois et pour vous les escalade est
nécessaire pour la victoire oui et
aujourd'hui la victoire est nécessaire
il s'agit depuis un an on a bien compris
maintenant qu'il s'agit pas pour Poutine
de déduire seulement l'Ukraine mais de
détruire l'ensemble de l'ordre européen
démocratique et donc il faut maintenant
non plus défendre les Ukrainiens mais
les laisser les faire gagner merci
beaucoup Claude Malleret d'être venu au
micro de Public Sénat merci merci
beaucoup Alexandra on va continuer tous
les commentaires après cette séance mais
on vous retrouve à nouveau avec Agnès
panière une HLA ministre de la
transition énergétique et cela alors que
député et sénateurs se sont hier mis
d'accord sur un texte commun autour du
projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables et pourtant ce n'était pas
gagné c'est à VOUS Alexandre ce n'était
pas gagné cet accord entre les deux
chambres du Parlement sur ce projet de
loi qui accélère le développement de nos
énergies renouvelables madame la
ministre c'est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite par l'accord qui a été trouvé
entre député et sénateurs sur ce texte
je crois que la méthode que j'ai mise en
place pour co-construire ce texte et
effectivement prendre en compte tous les
enrichissements les avancées que les
députés les sénateurs ont souhaité
apporter au texte ben cette méthode elle
a porté ses fruits on a pu montrer qu'on
était capable sur un sujet qui était
historiquement très sensible de dégager
un accord un accord qui est au
rendez-vous de l'histoire parce que il
nous faut produire plus d'énergie plus
d'énergie à bas prix et plus d'énergie
plus d'énergie qui soit bas carbone pour
protéger notre planète c'est ce que
permet ce texte de loi donc oui je salue
cet accord j'espère qu'il sera voté dans
les prochains jours pour que nous nous
mettions maintenant au travail pour
déployer cette loi et faire en sorte que
tous les élus locaux et les instruments
pour déployer justement cette
indépendance énergétique qu'ils
appellent de leur vœu et concrètement
dans les prochains mois les prochaines
années qu'elles vont être les
conséquences de cette loi en termes
c'est d'abordation de l'énergie
renouvelable c'est d'abord un gain de
temps puisque je prends l'exemple de
l'éolien marin les mesures que nous
prenons vont permettre de gagner
plusieurs années